[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
good evening you capitalist pigs
you know there once was a time when I
loved my audience you were the smartest
bravest most unique collection of people
anywhere most of you were paper trained
and could take a punch
it's like a circus except all the
bearded ladies are at swim meets
a Forbes Magazine while I was in the
waiting room at my gynecologist
you know they once they once loved their
audience too but no more you remember
the magazine used to be focused on
helping readers invest money build
wealth and Achieve Better Lives for
themselves and their families they were
bought by a front for China China's
Sovereign wealth fund but I'm sure that
wouldn't influence the viewpoints right
but now thanks to Forbes I finally
understand that wealth is actually evil
just like the readers this from the
magazine founded by Malcolm Forbes a man
so loaded he had Faberge eggs for
breakfast
and of course you know what that means
capitalism is evil which means America
is evil which means all of you are evil
just like Shannon bream
yeah Forbes has your number terrible
people let's look at a few recent
headlines quote wake up be woke and lead
the change overcoming Dei opposition
here writer Amelia ungarasan taught me
that my resistance to going woke is due
to my fear of change my fear of losing
power and privilege and of course my
bias and my Prejudice what a relief
right I thought it was because I'm
allergic to
yeah
on gurusan which I think is Mongolian
for Brooklyn cat lady
then runs through the ways to overcome
this bias including transparent
communication sounds like when I talk to
Kat on a phone through prison Plexiglas
but to the left transparent
communication means sit quietly while I
scream at you here's another instructive
gem from Forbes is the war on woke a war
on our country's future writer Jeff
rakes opines that the right wants to
strip gays of their hard-won human
rights and that to conservatives woke is
the new communism the big scary word to
rile up people and hold the fractious
GOP caucus together yeah rakes is so
right I didn't know that all you jerks
want is gays not to vote
have you no shame I for one want voting
to be more gay friendly like having
booths with glory holes
now now if you think look
if you think I make too many juvenile
gay sex jokes may I remind you I have
several gay men on my staff
now comes the latest piece in Forbes to
hate on evil capitalists Mark Travers
explained something called The Wealth
love Paradox he details some goofy
studies that link getting rich with
unethical Behavior including their quote
lacks attitude towards rules they're
skewed ethical Compass they're in
consideration and they're over emphasis
on winning
sounds like my old match.com profile
but in other words affluent people are
the worst
so what is Forbes at this point what
used to be an icon of wealth is now
crapping on the engine that kept them
afloat I haven't seen a magazine insult
its audience like that since Playboy
featured Rosie O'Donnell
foreign
but you know it's not just Forbes these
days Wall Street heavily favors donating
to Dems over Republicans so what if
illegal immigrants overwhelm the schools
their kids go private your daughter lost
a bike race to a man by her a faster
Ferrari
yeah even our moneyed class has been
infected with the woke mind virus maybe
it was from the eight coveted shots
so what in the name of Adam Smith is
going on here well clearly there's some
self serious self-hating going on I
haven't seen anyone beat on himself this
hard since Carlos Danger
but the truth is while they try to cloak
it in calls for equity and diversity
nothing Riles up progressives like
American success
for all its flaws this country Remains
the most successful experiment in human
governance of all time nowhere else will
self-reliance and hard work be so
reliably rewarded where else can an
African immigrant become the richest man
in the world with nothing more than his
brain and a hair transplant
will success happen every time of course
not will it happen for every person nope
and sometimes you'll get rewarded even
though you're nothing but a drain on
society
foreign
but look not everyone can have a hit
book a hit show and be sexy at the same
time thank you no no no no no not her
no
not him either
who is this
cameraman
my cousin
anyway for all their whiny virtue
signaling what the Forbes crew can't
refute is that America's capitalist
system is not only why people here can
achieve so much success it's also why
America continues to lead the world
even when our current leader sometimes
goes astray
and it's why someone is actually willing
to pay them to write these stupid
cliches but here's the great news for
Forbes new Census Data claims U.S
household incomes fell for the third
straight year and as a Wall Street
Journal notes thanks to the high cost of
housing and economic downturns more and
more baby boomers are becoming homeless
so whose basements will their kids live
in
so problem solve looks like Forbes will
get its way soon the rich won't be able
to do bad things because they won't
exist and we'll all be poor but you know
really good people because the poor are
angels hell if Forbes gets its way we'll
be taking Financial advice from these
folks
look the bottom line America isn't known
as the land of precisely equal outcomes
where the land of opportunity and
opportunity means you have to work for
it you have to earn it and here are so
many from so many backgrounds still can
and still do you know take me for
instance I started out as a wisecracking
columnist for a small magazine and now I
own 10 slaughterhouses
but it's why there isn't exactly a line
waiting until you get into Uruguay
except from their neighbors Paraguay and
loser guay
so you know what I guess I love you all
again and you know why because you've
earned your success despite what Forbes
believes whatever level of the American
dream you've achieved you and your
families are entitled to enjoy it
starting with tonight's show
[Applause]
comedian Joe DeRosa
his name rhymes with Colombo which means
he's no Dumbo co-founder of based
politics Brad Palumbo
thank you
her arms can be used as fly swatters New
York Times best-selling author and Fox
News contributor Kat Tim
and Pennsylvania police found 100 Escape
convicts hiding in his shoes
Times best
of Joe DeRosa how are you just great
Greg you look fantastic thank you so
much you know I earned this you did you
are
and people know this but Joe is a small
business owner you run a sandwich shop
downtown what's it called Joe's Subs
Joey roses Greg yes yes I've never been
there don't plan to go I don't go much
often myself either
but I have a nice staff yes you do you
enjoy ruining the lives of so many
people with your capitalist values
absolutely yeah uh I pay well I'm here
to say I paid a ton of dues yeah and I
have nothing
but I've earned every bit of it I've
earned every bit of it but I have
absolutely nothing right why is that
uh I I actually like to you mentioned
the land of opportunity and one of the
opportunities you have in America is to
do just enough to get by yes and that's
what I've done that's true yeah John
I've done what I feel like doing with a
real chip on my shoulder for the last 20
years and it's been good enough to pay
rent in New York city so I don't give a
damn
oh Joe you never change no I know Joey
roses 174 Rivington Street yeah
you know it's still open
Brad what does it say when Forbes is
complaining about capitalism is this
like a is it like a zombie product or
something yeah you know what it is is I
think for a long time we thought the
woke stuff would just stay on college
campuses but now we're seeing it leave
the campus go with them into their jobs
in Corporate America in big media
Outlets like Forbes because I can tell
you look I'm on YouTube I'm on Tick Tock
I see this kind of Eat the Rich
mentality all the time but they don't
realize how blind they are to how much
the successes of capitalism are
ingrained in their life all around them
right these folks get Amazon packages
delivered to their door the same day
they're liking tweets calling for Jeff
Bezos to be sent to the guillotine yes
and what they don't seem to realize is
that in under capitalism some people get
stupid rich but they do it unless
they're colluding with the government or
doing something sketchy they do it by
meeting other people's needs you know
it's estimated only about two percent of
the wealth that innovators create
actually goes in their bank accounts so
I wish people like this they should be
lauding the Jeff bezos's of the world
not bitching and learning about them
yeah I think Joe can identify it with
the two percent
Joe you probably made about two percent
off your sandwich shop two percent
that's very good that's very generous of
you uh cat I know this is an obvious
point but there are good rich people
there are good poor people there are bad
rich people there are bad poor people
the problem with this mentality is The
Human Condition is not reflected by
group assumptions but individual
qualities yet in the woke world all we
see or supposed to see are groups yeah
there was several paragraphs devoted to
how rich men cheat in relationships yes
which is an interesting way of letting
me know that the author of this person
never dated a broke guy
they cheat too yeah
yeah more time on their hands
you don't have a job like you know
you'll be at work and they'll be at work
too
in a different way so I I like I I don't
know I mean it's easier to demonize I
guess than it is to maybe acknowledge
that maybe you didn't get what you
wanted to get out of life which I think
people do all the time and when it comes
to a lot of different things and money's
just no different yeah it's true you
know tires I've never been mugged by a
rich person but I've never been swindled
by a poor person so why do we have to
continue to talk like these are
different people
well we need to first of all when Rich
guys cheat it's called Outsourcing um
[Laughter]
and when women do it it's called our
fault
so it all works out
this is virtue signaling at the highest
form she's not donating her check each
week to to the the homeless shelters and
the orphans she's sitting up on her
perch from her from her office sipping
her tea going you guys really don't want
this this is such a burden be so
thankful that you're in the squalor it's
better there I wish I could be there
with you but I have to stay here
and just watch you this is eliminate the
competition set the bar low you know
minorities stop trying to come up you
can't you just because you know
minorities but no and and white people
you're racist and just stick to your
plantations and your old school money
and your privilege and don't worry we'll
take it from here and that's what you do
you set that mob mentality to where
everyone's at each other's throats and
you are just sitting back in the luxury
of your first world department just
narrating for us like you're not Morgan
Freeman you're a hypocrite and they all
are hypocrites because when something
happens to them then it's an individual
sport right because if she got mugged
she wants that guy he needs to go yeah
we need to get if he was an illegal
alien we got to do something about the
Border if he was a brother like we got
to stop rap music if he was white no
more cowboy hats like they go all of a
sudden it's an individual Sport and
that's exactly what this is she's in a
very safe place and she's an equity hire
so no one's going to challenge her
because if they do
yeah you're racist yeah or sexist or
whatever so it's a beautiful time to be
a writer right now because there's no
checks and balances just add race to
every story Joe last word it's gonna say
with Cyrus it's very interesting it's
like that classic kind of religious
hustle yeah oh it shall inherit the
earth right you know and there's that
Zappa song The Michelle and Herod
nothing which is the real truth yep stay
poor Stay Stay wanting stay needing it's
righteous now look away as I sip out of
a gold chalice and don't think about how
you can get your hands on one of these
all right
your sandwiches are delicious thank you
I just want to let you know I appreciate
it I had three different kinds that were
phenomenal thank you very much man I
appreciate that Greg's never been cat's
never been well when you brought them
all in one room I did have them yeah I
have always peanut butter jelly
phenomenal no they're it don't laugh
there's a peanut butter
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else